citizens of reject nation we are back
with post comic con coy's comic corner
you may notice all those c have a little
gravel to them because your boy koi khan
so crud and hard i hosted hall age i did
my first ever hall age i hosted a comic
book in all age the first host to host
to comic con hall h and i had an amazing
panel with jim starlin an amazing panel
wv games and just general comic-con
merriment when you add all those things
together you have no more voice so i do
apologize for the gravel in my voice
that said please do leave a like leave a
comment notify yourself by hitting that
bell up there and subscribe to us i have
a ton more video ideas i want to bring
to you and that brings me to the
comments please do comment below what
you want to see more of we just got an
onslaught for a lot more marvel content
to come and i want to know what you want
to hear about most please do follow me
on tik tok i do 15 second 30 second one
minute three minute videos over there
and i'm gonna be doing a whole bunch
talking about all of this stuff to come
i'm trying to crank out like three or
four videos a day this video is going to
be about phase five and six's marvel
announcements so far that does mean i'm
not going to be including she-hulk and
wakanda forever in this particular video
you all know how excited i am for shield
that comes out in just a couple of weeks
and i will say briefly that wakanda
forever trailer i knew would be
beautiful i knew it'd be mesmerizing i
didn't know how brutal that would feel
it was such a stunning experience of
seeing that trailer and seeing it in
hall h with that crowd i'd been crying
all throughout the whole age panel um
because it was all so emotional but that
that particular trailer resonated in a
way i didn't think i'd feel from a
trailer and it's just mesmeric and
wonderful so we'll kind of forever would
be so high up on this list if it was
phase five or six well connor forever is
not on this list because we're gonna do
phase five and six let's kick it off
[Music]
number 15 and you guys are gonna hate me
and you're gonna leave a lot of comments
and i know it's coming but i am
genuinely excited for all these this is
just the one i'm
least of the excitement and that is echo
i really really enjoy the character of
echo i think she is fascinating i think
she is important but as per the movies
and shows we have so far lowest on the
list i did enjoy her portrayal in
hawkeye but i never found myself going
like i need more of her whereas the top
14 i genuinely cannot wait to see each
of these characters again so echo by
default is on the lower side that said
we don't have a single trailer yet if
the trailer comes out and that changes
that would change this whole thing but
having it be the unknown having it be
the least of my pulls number 15. number
14 was agatha all along number 14 is
going to be the agatha harkness show
which i am very excited about especially
since i do think it involves dr doom in
a way there's a certain other elements
some mysticism but that's another video
uh that said i do think agatha harkness
is a really interestingly duplicitous
character i think catherine hahn had a
lot to do in wanda vision she was able
to add a lot of heart to this character
i'm a big fan of the character bag of
darkness because she's from salem mass
i'm a massachusetts kid and i do think
the way catherine han portrayed her was
even more interesting than some of her
comic book counterparts ability to
really bring that multi-faceted element
but that said as far as a show i want to
see more of her i'm just not sure what
they're going to do with that character
we haven't seen a trailer we haven't
seen any of this so currently it's low
just because i don't know which
direction they're taking her inner solo
number 13 is iron heart and this one is
this high on the list almost completely
because of the actress playing riri
williams she was
rigory williams on that stage the moment
she spoke at hall h i was like that's
riri i literally tweeted out oh my god
she sounds exactly like riri her word
choices the cadence in her speech
sounded like how i imagined bendis the
entire aura she brought to the character
has that incredible slightly smart
alecky smart snarky smart like there's a
certain nest to how she's got little
verbal barbs and there's this confidence
in the way she carries herself i was so
impressed with this actress i actually
met her at a party after later that
night and we talked about bendis and the
way she feels about that almost
shakespearean
there's almost an amic pentameter to the
way that she and rigri williams speak
this is a show i'm very excited about i
cannot wait to see ironheart come to
life big fan of this comic big fan of
this actress already overjoyed to see
this on the screen my number 12 is
captain america new world order now i am
excited for this because i'm really
enchanted by the idea of seeing a
different take on captain america i
really enjoy the sam wilson captain
america comics i think they're gonna go
with probably a moral militant police
force there's a whole thing about a new
world order in the comic books involving
a very authoritative police force i
think where this ties into phase four
leading into five where we're seeing a
lot of the department of damage control
we're we're seeing a lot of almost
fascist government things in the comic
books i think we're gonna get more and
more authoritative in the comic books i
think this captain america movie's gonna
take that on the head i don't
necessarily think we're getting a
multiversal cap i think this is our sam
wilson i don't think we're getting hydra
steve rogers because there's no way that
that chris evans sullies his captain
america by coming back to play a villain
i don't see either of those happening
personally if chris evans gets a script
that's really strong for hydrocap maybe
but i think the way he sees his arc is
done it's solved it's it's everything
it's over that being said i do think an
aggressive police force versus what it
would be like to see sam wilson in the
role of cap is much more interesting
commentary in the world today and it
mirrors the sam wilson captain america
comics better and it allows for a lot
more of the new falcon to do post falcon
in the winter soldiers so this is one
i'm really excited for following up that
show which i do think is a bit slept on
as well as the world we're living in
today as well as the comics that i love
very much number 11 i am so very excited
for this because of the end of miss
marvel i think we're going to have such
a good time seeing miss marvel
interacting with captain marvel
interacting with spectrum or photon
whichever name they go with for that
incredible portrayal of the character i
think the three of them are gonna have
an amazing time i think we're gonna have
some cosmic high jinks i think we're
gonna have some developments earthbound
as far as the development of what the
dodc is does leading up to thunderbolts
i think we're gonna have a lot of really
interesting cosmic meeting earthbound
dynamic and the way we have aman valani
playing ms marvel as this incredible
fanboy of the marvel universe is going
to be beautifully reflecting captain
marvel's stoic-ness i think we're
finally going to find a way to make the
brie larson captain marvel as dynamic as
i know brie larson playing captain
marvel can be the more we've seen her
play this character post captain marvel
the more have been endeared to her i
love brie larson i want to see the miss
marvel captain marvel that i think amman
and brie can do plus nina acosta
directed the hell out of a movie that i
really loved called candyman the visual
aesthetic that style she's already
filmed the post-credits scene of miss
marvel i'm already intrigued by this new
costume this new flavor of brie larson's
move plus nida costa directing this is
very high up on my list i know the
number 11 doesn't seem high but that's
because we're at peak height number 10
this one is high because i finally saw
some footage of it and the footage
looked so good ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania i've been saying for a
very long time is going to be a much
bigger movie impact-wise for the mcu
than ant-man one and two they very
consciously seem to make the ant-man
movies short of a post-credits scene
kind of over here like they they have
scott lang who's you know he's fine but
in the avengers ant-man the other
ant-man hank pym was a founding member
he's a very important character i could
see this movie being as essential to the
avengers films going forward as your
iron mans and your captain america's i
think this movie is going to be
essential because it brings us kang
there's a reason this kicks off phase
five i think the reason we're shaping
phase five the way we are is kang we
know that's heading towards phase six
the use of kang in this movie plus how
stunning visually this looked i talked
to peyton reed and some of his
influences and style choices and
everything he's building here are art it
looks astounding there is so much scope
there's so much humor there's so much of
the things we love about the first two
but adding avengers level scope means i
think we'll get everything i love about
ant-man plus everything i love about the
iron man and avengers movies in one
beautiful package i think a lot of
people are gonna be surprised at how
much they're gonna love quantum mania
and the footage was amazing number nine
thunderbolts thunderbolts is so so so
high on my list because i think it is so
so so important i've been saying all
over ms marvel that thunderbolts is
going to be a big shift in the mcu i
think there's a reason thunderbolts ends
phase 5. this is going to be an avengers
level event this is avengers but dark
this is a dark avengers film and that's
effectively the combination of two books
i think they're making this movie out to
be we need going forward in the mcu to
distrust heroes the universe needs to
distrust heroes we're gonna love them
but we need to have the world where we
can have the x-men that are hate and
fear we can have different dynamics of
why heroes need masks the comic books
are getting more and more represented in
the costumes we're getting more and more
accurate to storyline distrust of heroes
because of things like secret invasion
and thunderbolts you're going to see a
lot of the population start to distrust
these characters because of secret
invasion because we're going to find out
a lot of heroes are revealed to be
aliens then in thunderbolts that's all
gonna come to a head when a team of
avengers is revealed to be evil this
thunderbolts movie is the way that phase
six happens in my opinion i'm wondering
if by the end of this they have to go
back in time using kang stuff to even
fix the opinion of yours i think
thunderbolts is going to be enormous i
think it's going to be a giant 250 plus
million dollar movie i think the scope
is going to be absolutely insane and
it's something we haven't really seen
before i think thunderbolts is the
closest to an avengers level event that
we have in phase five and i think that
it's going to surprise a lot of people
this one's my number nine number eight
loki season two the sequel to my
favorite of the marvel shows so far this
show is hard to even explain why i'm
excited because it's just based off how
much i loved season one we don't know
where it's gonna go the tva is kind of
in a state of flux whether or not it
even exists like what's that gonna be
we've seen some like behind the scenes
footage looks like loki goes mcdonald's
like what is happening what i know is
that justin and aaron uh justin benson
and aaron moorhead are making a show and
that's following up on their incredible
visual style and aesthetic and all of
their properties most recently moon
knight that is going to be tiny why me
insane and that we're getting mobius
back just the knowledge we're gonna get
another existential crisis of a show
with tom hiddleston and owen wilson is
enough the fact that the first season
was so good puts this really high up for
me but the fact that we don't really
know what it's about and the fact that
kang is so formative to where we're
going it's going to involve time travel
it's going to involve kang and maybe
traveling through time i theorize it's
going to be them kind of chasing the
threads of what kang has undone i think
kang is going to be a behind the scenes
manipulator all theory that they're
going to have to solve a lot of the
problems of showing us just how big of a
bad he is again conjecture theory but no
matter what even if it doesn't involve
kang it's a sequel to that incredible
season of television that i cannot wait
for number seven might have the hardest
task of anything in this video number
seven is not an avengers property which
sounds like it'd be hard number seven is
not a sequel to a property that's
beloved which sounds like it is hard
this is a reboot of wesley snipes's
blade that series is near perfect i love
the blade movies the blade movies are
how the mcu exists it is a very very
hard bite to chew and do it right that's
a bad metaphor but i was thinking of a
vampire thing my point is they have a
lot to chew this is big this is enormous
and mahershala ali is one of the best to
do it so if anyone can he can i'm so
excited for this i cannot imagine a more
difficult way to launch into the
supernatural because we're all going to
be wanting this to be as good as the og
blade but that means if it does succeed
if it's as good as the old blade was and
ties into the mcu if it's able to be
this incredible vampire world that
incorporates all the supernatural
leading to the midnight suns which is
what i think it's going to be and brings
us a blade that we love as much as
wesley snipes this will be one of the
all-time great mcu properties this says
the hardest thing to do but it has the
most potential to be the best all the
ingredients are there all the hype is
there all of the want is there i think
blade is going to be very special number
six guardians of the galaxy three i love
these two movies so much and the first
one is in my top four mcu films i am
obsessed with the world james gunn has
built i saw the new trailer at comic-con
it broke me it is so emotional it is so
visually stunning it is riveting it was
just such a
kick in the stomach and i think high
evolutionary personally maybe spoilers
theories this is i don't know but i
think high evolutionary is going to be
responsible for making rocket raccoon i
think this is going to be a movie about
the saddest creature in the universe
rocket and i think we're going to see
the horrors of how he came from and i
think the guardians as a family are
gonna be wanting revenge on that
character and i think it's gonna be a
really brutal revenge tale where our
hero's gonna have to do awful things i
think high evolutionary is gonna be a
terrifying villain i think the use of
james gunn and the way he sees the world
we're gonna see some horrific things
we're gonna see animals mutated human
sentient beings as well as animals just
be manipulated into being evolved and i
think that's an interesting commentary
on on our real world atrocities the way
people see things as involved the way
people see things as beneath them i
think this villain might not be as big
as an overarching villain as kang but i
think it might be the most traumatic
villain to the viewer and i think our
empathy for groot and rocket and the
rest of the guardians is really going to
be tested when this all falls apart and
i think a lot of people are going gonna
die i think this movie might be the most
brutal movie in the mcu and i'm very
excited for it in a very bittersweet way
because it does end our guardian saga
but it looks perfect this trailer is
everything so it's high up number six is
guardians number five is fantastic for
full disclosure we usually do all these
in one take but this is the second take
as i started explaining why i'm excited
fantastic four and i'm actually gonna
make that another video i've got so many
things to say about doctor doom then
that's gonna be a separate video please
watch it this week that said fantastic
four i'm excited about because
i think this is the best opportunity to
find the best things of the other
fantastic four movies use all of those
like how cinematic these characters are
human torch thing sue storm mr fantastic
are all very visually appealing there's
a reason this is one of the first
superhero teams to do as well this
character set has been around since the
beginning of marvel this is marvel's
first family both in title and reality
this is an important set of characters
that haven't been done right i think
they know how important this is i think
they're investing so much into this
entire world i think there's a reason
it's coming in phase six again there's
gonna be a doctor doom video but most of
all i think this is the marvel chance to
make something that feels new while
still being a team i think this could be
very heartwarming and endearing and
different and wholesome and i don't
think we've seen anything quite like the
comic book fantastic four in any
superhero universe this has a lot of
expectations but if it lands it's gonna
be really really important to the
greater mcu i'm very excited for my hope
for the fantastic four number four
secret invasion this is probably the
biggest leap up in expectation to
delivery i really didn't expect a ton
from segan invasion i like the comic i
don't love the comic it's beloved by
many it's just not one of my favorites
the art is gorgeous the story is a lot
of fun it's very conspiratorial but it
never landed for me the same way it has
for a lot of other people again i love a
lot of the factors of it but it's not
one of my all-time greats that said the
trailer they showed us the footage we
saw is every bit the 70s espionage
thriller that i love about winter
soldier but with even more paranoia with
even more a sense of ominous doom
everything about this show looks
incredible that the stacked cast looks
like it's going to deliver really well
they didn't even have to show a scroll
really in the secret invasion footage to
have me absolutely invested and it also
looks to kind of walk that line between
r-rated and pg-13 in a way that
daredevil did on netflix this show looks
genuinely and i hate that these are buzz
words because it kind of eliminates the
hype generally dark gritty and adult in
all the ways i want to see the
difference of these shows being this
feels like a show you could watch with
your grandparents just like the redford
element of winter soldier this footage
really impressed me it was actually my
number one takeaway from the entire hour
at hall h was how much i was surprised
that secret invasion kind of became my
most anticipated show this one's really
high for a reason big expectations on
this number four secret invasion number
three is the just recently announced
kang dynasty avengers kang dynasty this
could be every bit the insane time
travel elements we had with in-game but
on the scale of something we've never
even seen before arguably obviously end
game is giant scale but with kang
it's infinite possibility there's so
much they can do and i think as we
evolve with the surrealistic images of
multiverse of madness plus the insane
creative visual choices of love and
thunder we're gonna get more and more
dynamic and more and more comic book
accurate these visuals and the fact that
kang dynasty happens in like two and a
half years there's so much between now
and then where we can evolve not just
the visual aesthetic of the mcu but also
kang we're gonna see a ton of kang
leading up to this and more importantly
we're gonna see a ton of kangs we're
gonna see lots and lots of different
takes on jonathan major's character and
we're gonna see how that interweaves
into this whole tapestry and i think
this is going to be part one of two of
the movies that everyone from die hard
marvel fans to casual fans that want to
see all these cameos alike get to have
this is the cake and eat it two movie
part one of two cannot wait for it
number two and the reason for this shirt
daredevil born again we've now seen a
flash of the yellow suited daredevil in
that she-hulk footage we have seen a
taste of kingpin that to be honest i
didn't love the delivery of as much as
i've loved other things but i think that
marvel listens kevin feige knows exactly
what fans want the marvel industry
listens to these message boards and
videos like this where they know we want
these changes i think when we get
kingpin back for a whopping 18 episodes
we're gonna have the kingpin we want
from netflix i think when we get matt
murdock back for more than just a
beautiful wonderful uplifting cameo no
way home for 18 episodes especially
after i assume his appearance in both
she-hulk and another few properties
we've had charlie cox say over and over
again this is something that's going to
be happening for years that plus the
announcement of the number of episodes
plus where this falls in the mcu plus it
being born again plus the expectations
from the netflix show you ended the
netflix season 3 with a very catholic
guilt reborn already born again is a
beautiful comic arc and he's born again
within marvel i love all of this i love
the expectation i love the potential i
love the daredevil netflix show if this
can be even 75 as good for that kind of
run time this is gonna be a really
special property number one and looks
like phase six's end game it looks like
we're gonna have a kang dynasty followed
up by secret wars secret wars i think is
gonna be the culmination of not just
these four five and six phases i think
this is gonna be a phase one through six
culmination this concludes the
multiverse saga i think it's gonna
include everything from the multiverse i
think this could have all the characters
from fox we want all the characters from
sony that we want different
interpretations of the characters within
the mcu the multiverse of madness
delivered on the multiverse in that
section it gave us that wonderful john
krasinski cameo it gave us a captain
carter it gave us all these things we've
always wanted to see secret wars can do
that to a grander scale an enormous
scale it can do that throughout and the
story can be rich because all three of
the secret wars mini series are so
different so effective so psychedelic so
vast and it's going to be i think the
kang to doom thanos situation i think
we're gonna see you know what i'm gonna
save that that's gonna go in the doom
video but i do think we're gonna see
lots and lots of elements that are part
one and part two and part two might be
the biggest marvel movie to date i think
secret wars could be an absolutely
enormous undertaking if they deal with
all the time travel in the kang dynasty
where i think we're gonna land at the
end of seeker wars is gonna be very very
special and i think we're gonna have six
different phases of build up where end
game was built up from three phases and
12 years this could be built up from
almost 20 years of movie making i think
it comes out in three years for a reason
i think we're going to have to put a lot
of things together to make this work and
kevin feige looks at a 10 year plan he's
probably calling actors from fox and
sony right now to cook it up up this
insane mega event movie the likes of
which we've never seen in a film before
i think this is going to make that
endgame scene with avengers assemble
feel like the civil war scene when you
look back on it very beautiful very
intense a a double page spread come to
life but comparatively small in-game is
the biggest thing we've ever experienced
in movies in this genre to date i think
secret wars is gonna make that look
small and that is saying a lot i also am
really invested in whether or not it's
the russos it's my number one because
just those two words secret wars are
something comic fans have always wanted
to hear throwing avengers on top of that
this is
literally everything it is my number one
most anticipated and to be honest i'm
glad it's so far away we need fantastic
four first we need everything we know of
in phase four and after the events of
d23 they're gonna be filling out that
phase six board and we're gonna have a
better idea what secret wars is gonna be
and i cannot wait to dive into that when
it happens this has been my most
anticipated 15 properties of phases five
and six once we get to d23 we're gonna
like i said no a not more but until then
this is where i'm at what are you most
excited about which of these properties
is your number one most anticipated
again not best not favorite what has you
the most excited let me know in the
comments let me know if any of these 15
are something you'd like me to dive into
more and talk about more and let me know
what theories you have below thank you
very much reject nation i am honored to
be a citizen as well as someone speaking
to you about all of this comic book
glory go read some comics please for me
the books
they're so special try them out you
might dig them as much as i do all right
much love
[Music]
you